hey guys it's lex and i'm jordan and
today we are trying a weird pickle snack
ooh
i hate pickles
oh no
i'm like super daunted oh wait what if
we did not see this we didn't see this
oh tahin
oh
no
[Music]
oh my wait i'm like kind of intrigued by
this i think i might like it actually
okay i'm really nervous
i'm excited i'm ready for it though i'm
ecstatic to try this with you and be
here with this journey
oh my gosh this is sugar it's sugar it's
just
brings me back to like childhood
memories i will say your pickle's like a
little bit thicker than mine oh no
you could switch picks yeah we should we
should switch there we go amazing how'd
you get it so like nicely
because i wasn't allowed to have these
as a kid they used to make these with
like tattoos on them did you ever do
that yes that was my favorite thing i
was hoping these were gonna have tattoos
you say you're wrapping a little baby
little tiny baby
how's it going over there
we've gone such different methods for
our wrapping technique
i think yours looks pretty
really yeah i think she's looking kind
of thick
like i don't know how many cuts i mean
she is thick though she is thick she had
thick piss it's so crazy that like my
first time having pickle
it's like with candy in the fruit
it kind of looks like spicy ketchup you
ready
it's like a little spice so they just
like kind of drizzled it on
and then like lightly massaged it in
go like that this is my this is my
strategy
why are you going straight
i wish you guys could like feel what i'm
feeling right now because it is terrible
you're right your way was better
i'll admit it
[Music]
now we roll it on the teen yeah
you take it and you just like
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes please and then we just all right
let's see this
wow
i'm smelling mcdonald's right now it
kind of feels like i'm cutting up like a
bacon wrap like scallop almost okay
that's i think that's good okay we're
just getting we're done okay time to try
it all right i'm taking this one this
one looks really cute to me this one
this one looks well small
it's small oh there's like juice
three two one
[Music]
not bad
i like it i'm getting like sour shivers
it's good though it's actually like way
better than i thought it was gonna be
but i'm also like tearing up from the
sour
i just
it's hard to see
i feel like it's just flavors that just
aren't supposed to be together okay i
agree
i'm not gonna eat another one but it's
good i am okay
okay
the internet oh you like it yeah i don't
love the fruit roll of like um chewiness
it made it kind of difficult to eat
it's so sour well the only thing that i
like out of this is the fruit roll up in
the fruit by the foot
it's a little boring well after having
that i prefer a regular pickle but this
thing is weird and probably should be
tried by everyone at least once i would
eat this as a snack i liked it all but i
didn't like it all at the same time keep
it on your toes you know keep guessing
well yeah i'm glad i tried it and hey be
open to new experiences
[Music]